have you ever wanted to get away from it
all to just escape the boredom of
everyday life today we'll be discussing
one of the most popular themes in
present day anime the ISA Kai notion
this is when the main character gets
transported or trapped in another world
or dimension this could be due to
several reasons before whatever the
circumstance they're forced to survive
and deal with the new world and its
peculiarities
[Music]
number nine on the list is devil is a
part-timer devil is a part-timer is
probably one of the more absurd and fun
stories out there with a unique setup in
an alternate dimension at the final
crucial moment
Satan along with one of his generals our
CEO gets sucked through an
interdimensional portal unknown to them
the heroine Emilia also follows them and
here's where it gets fun of all places
they could land on it's in a modern-day
Tokyo that they land unfortunately for
them they're unable to use their powers
in this strange land they assume new
identities as Mao and Shiro and rent a
shabby apartment near Shinjuku to
survive in the jungle of modern life Mao
gets a job at McDonald's yep you heard
that right
having these great overpowered
characters go through their daily lives
and overcome the predicaments they face
will keep you smiling for sure if the
devil can struggle with everyday modern
life maybe there's a chance yet for all
of us
[Music]
at number eight we have log horizon the
premise for long horizon isn't really
new it focuses on the idea of being
trapped in an MMORPG this has been done
a few times now however it's still quite
refreshing for several different reasons
Elder tale is the conventional fantasy
MMO game that the players are trapped in
however in the story of long horizon the
players become the in-game avatars that
they're playing with this is a highly
captivating journey as we progress with
our hero sheera who must learn to live
in this new world lead others and
negotiate with the NPC natives in order
to bring stability to the virtual city
of Akihabara if you enjoy stories that
experiment with sociological or even
economical themes no Corizon doesn't
disappoint it offers something different
from the usual shows as there's lots of
world building that takes place
[Applause]
number 7 we have drifters an anime based
on the manga of Helsing creates a kata
here on ooo this is a show about
historical warriors called drifters who
were transported to a fantasy Kingdom by
a mysterious organization that keeps
tabs on their activities the two main
characters Shimazu and Nasu are pulled
from Japanese battlefields from
different time periods and a team-up
with none other than Oda Nobunaga from
the very first scene drifters is as
merrily violent and over-the-top as you
might expect and the war within that
will have you leaping back and forth
between your favorite sights
it's Drifters versus ends in a battle of
historical pawns this is definitely a
show where fans of generation spanning
action will want to stick around through
to the bitter end
Davidson edition cougar and number six
it's the boy and the Beast from Mamoru
Hosoda the creator of wolf children and
the girl who left through time the boy
and the beasts a beautiful film and
story that explores the relationship
between an average Japanese boy named
Ren and a mythical beast known as
kumatetsu Ren's
run away from home after the death of
his mother his father doesn't seem to be
around and he despises all the other
members of his family so he starts
living in the streets of Tokyo kumatetsu
wanders around Tokyo and ends up taking
renin as a disciple at its core this is
a story of two worlds colliding the
human world with the beasts world this
is wonderfully shown in the conflicts
and growing bond between the two the
chemistry between them is quite fun to
watch and it really does establish a
bond of family between the two the
stunning visuals as well as the amazing
soundtrack make it quite engaging for
everyone to get absorbed and completely
take in a fun adventure waiting to
happen
the next entry on the list at number
five is Overlord Overlord brings up a
very relatable theme for anyone who's
played an MMORPG before that of a
favorite game being abandoned the
protagonist a player who goes by the
name Momonga has been a devoted player
of the virtual reality MMO game Idris
ill after investing days weeks and years
into building his skeletal character and
his guild into one of the most notorious
in the game he finds himself alone with
his world coming to an end a world he's
grown to love immensely so when the time
comes to pull the plug on the servers
and he finds himself trapped inside this
new reality he seriously contemplates
the question if you could go back to the
real world would he even want to
what makes overlord stand out is its
different perspective what happens if
the villain is stuck in a game world
overlord answers this question and goes
back deeper into the realms of personal
morality having to take a backseat to
keep up appearances and with the cast of
amusing demons it ensures you'll have a
good time on your hands
[Music]
next up a number four and easily the
funniest anime on the list it's gone a
tsuba have you ever played any role
playing games where you had to party up
and take on quest as a group pretty fun
right but what if you actually end up
with some pretty useless members you
know such as someone who usually gets
eaten by a giant frog or who'd wipe out
the entire party after causing a huge
explosion or for that matter at night
who misses with every swing of her sword
well that's basically the premise of
Kanna Zuba with the only useful member
being the one with the weakest stats the
story takes place after a traffic
accident when kazuma's disappointingly
brief life has supposedly come to an end
but surprisingly he's transported to a
fantasy world filled with adventure and
on the verge of being ruled by a demon
king grouped with an obnoxious goddess
named aqua masochistic Crusader darkness
and mega men an arch wizard who can only
really use one spell this group of
misfits makes for an entertaining show
as they plan their escape from their
various predicaments
why do you want Cucuy
[Music]
and number three we have no game no life
imagine being stuck in a world where the
whole world itself is a game the story
centers around two brilliant gamers Sora
and Shiro a brother and sister duo who
are legends on the internet they
consider the real world is just another
crappy game and generally avoided as
much as possible one day they're
summoned by a boy named tete the god of
games to an alternate world of dis board
here
God has prohibited war and declared it
to be a world where everything will be
decided by games even the national
borders are decided by games everything
is settled by predetermined stakes
spirit ones memories or even the right
to rule it's quite an interesting setup
that allows for a lot of intellectual
moments it's a fun adventure well worth
the watch if you haven't seen it already
[Music]
at number two its rezero re0 is a
psychological anime which came with an
interesting concept at a time it was
released because of some of the darker
consequences it hinted at the story
revolves around an eighteen year old boy
named Nazi Subaru who suddenly
teleported to a fantasy world a kingdom
where humans demons spirits and deme
humans coexist there he meets and
eventually falls in love with a silver
head half elf named Stella what makes
this anime quite unique is that Subaru
figures out that he's able to time leave
every time he dies this is similar to a
video game where after you die you'll
respond to a start point
however in rezero this implies a much
deeper meaning and finally at number one
its spirited away no list of different
world scenarios can end without at least
mentioning this anime this story follows
ten-year-old Chihiro
her parents are moving into a new place
in the suburbs however on the way to
their new home which by the way G hero's
not looking forward to it all they take
a side trip and end up in a strange
eerie oriental town with curiosity at
this strange new place she wanders
around the town completely devoid of
humans this town appears to be a resting
spot for Japanese spirits where they can
relax in hot baths and generally have a
good time this includes eating good food
which unfortunately includes her parents
who've just so happened to turn into
pigs two heroes journey to try to free
her parents is an amazing tale told with
boundless imagination the beautiful and
complex imagery communicates an
atmosphere and feel that's literally out
of this world so what do you think about
this list their name and which is your
favorite anime out of these comment
below and let us know don't forget to
leave a like if you enjoyed the video
subscribe if you want to see more anime
related content and leave a comment of
what top-10 you'd like to see me do next
I'll see you next time on Vinnie tube
[Music]